هو الان ندخل الان تقريبا نقترب من الشهر
الثالث لبدء التوغل في خان يونس الاطراف
الشرقيه في بدايه ديسمبر ان كنت تذكرين
ازدهار في المنطقه الجنوبيه من قطاع غزه
بدايه ديسمبر الاسبوع الاول من شهر ديسمبر
الماضي دخل او بدات العمليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه البريه في التوغل من الجهه
الشرقيه بدرجه اساسيه باتجاه خانيونس الان
نتحدث عن المناطق الغربيه من خان يونس
وكان الاحتلال قد نفذ عمليه مناوره بريه
خلال خ الاسابيع الماضيه في المنطقه
الشرقيه والمنطقه الشماليه الشرقيه من خان
يونس كانت الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
قد اخترقت هذه المناطق من الجهه الجنوبيه
الشرقيه من خزاعه ومن الجهه الشرقيه عبسان
ووصلت الى بني سهيله في هذه النقطه على
الاطراف او او ما يعرف بالبوابه الشرقيه
لخان يونس شرقي شارع صلاح الدين وتمركزت
في بني سهيله وعند شارع صلاح الدين في
المنطقه الشرقيه من مدينه خان يونس ايضا
كانت الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه قد
توغلت من جهه القراره والزناه ولكنها نفذت
عمليه مناوره وانسحبت من هاتين المنطقتين
من جهه القراره في المنطقه الشماليه من
منطقه خانيونس الان الحديث يدور عن ضغط
على خانيونس من الجهه الشماليه ومن الجهه
الشماليه الغربيه اي اننا نتحدث عن هذا
المحور بهذا الشكل للضغط على خانيونس مع
تواصل الضغط من الجهه الشرقيه اذا ما
دخلنا بصوره اقرب لخريطه خان يونس فنحن
نتحدث عن مجموعه من التفاصيل التي استمعنا
استمعنا لها في الاخبار وسمعنا باسمها في
الاخبار خلال الساعات القليله الماضيه
نتحدث عن مستشفى الامل وهو مقر جمعيه هلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني ونتحدث عن مستشفى ناصر
في هاتين المنطقتين تدور على اطراف هاتين
المنطقتين تدور الاشتباكات كما ذكر
مراسلنا مؤمن شرافي خلال الساعات القليله
الماضيه تدور الاشتباكات ايضا في محيط
شارع خمسه هذا هو شارع خمسه الذي يربط بين
البحر وبين شارع صلاح الدين وهذا هو شارع
صلاح الدين كما نعلم الذي الذ يربط
المناطق الشماليه بالمناطق الجنوبيه في
قطاع غزه ويمر من خانيونس وينزل جنوبا الى
رفح اليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه توغلت من
جهه بني سهيله قطعت شارع صلاح الدين
وتمركزت عند مبنى البلديه لعده اسابيع
ماضيه خلال الثلاث اسابيع الماضيه على
الاقل كانت الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
متمركزه في مبنى البلديه ومحيط مبنى
البلديه بلديه خان يونس بطبيعه الحال في
الجهه الشرقيه من مدينه خانيونس تمركزت
هناك وتنفذ عمليات مناو
بريه في المناطق او في الاحياء الشرقيه
لخان يونس الان العمليه العسكريه التي
بدات خلال الساعات القليله الماضيه تتمركز
عند الجهه الشماليه والجهه الغربيه لقلب
مدينه خانس هذا هي هذا هو الهدف الذي تسعى
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي للتوغل فيه في
خان يونس ونحن نتحدث عن قلب مدينه خان
يونس اذا ما قسنا المساحات والمسافات فنحن
نتحدث عن من جهه الشرق نحو الغرب حوالي
اقل من 2 م م من جهه الشمال نحو الجنوب
نتحدث عن نفس المساحه تقريبا ونفس المسافه
تقريبا اقل من 2 م اي اننا نتحدث عن مساحه
لا تتجاوز 4 م مربع القصف الاسرائيلي الان
يتمركز في هذه النقطه المنطقه الغربيه من
مستشفى ناصر مجمع ناصر الطبي الذي يعتبر
عمليا المستشفى الوحيد الذي بقي يعمل
المقبره التي تحدث عنها مؤمن شرافي هذه هي
المقبره التي لا تبعد الا اقل من نصف كيل
متر حوالي 400 الى 500 متر فقط عن مستشفى
ناصر العمليات العسكريه والقصف الان يشتد
في المنطقه الغربيه من مستشفى ناصر وايضا
هناك اشتباكات في محيط مستشفى الامل اي
اننا نتحدث عن هذا المربع الذي بدا يضيق
فيه تضيق فيه عمليه الاشتباكات بعد ان
كانت خانيونس 4 كم تقريبا 4 م مربع تقريبا
لا يوجد فيها اشتباكات بدات الاشتباكات
الان نتحدث عن حوالي ثلاثه الى من اثنين
الى 3 م مربع تدور في ه الاشتباكات بكات
اي اننا نتحدث عن قلب مدينه خانيونس في
الجهه الغربيه لمنطقه خانيونس ونحن نتحدث
ايضا عن نقطه مهمه وهي ان هذه العمليه
تتجاوز او وصلت الان عمليا الى اقتربت من
شهرها الثاني نتحدث من بدايه ديسمبر
الاسبوع الاول من ديسمبر نحن على ابواب
الاسبوع الاول من فبراير هذا يعني ان
الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لم يستطع التوغل في هذه
المنطقه خلال خلال الاسابيع والشهور
القليله الماضيه وكانت معظم عملياته
العسكريه تدور في الجهه الشرقيه وهي عمليا
المناطق المفتوحه من خان يونس مع الضغط
الكبير للطيران والمدفعيه على كل الجها من
كل الجهات نحو قلب مدينه خان يونس كما
نشاهد في الخريطه هذ